if you look back at the carpark video
you'll see it's very handy everything's
cut and dried
every possible combination of twenties
tens and fives will work get us to 25
deliver a ticket if we turn to what we
were talking about briefly at the end of
that video something like I'm in a
program language and I want to declare
and identify a name for my integers I
want to call mine did you short and Dave
or even k9 I said last time well that's
fine but if you want arbitrary length
variable names how do you say I don't
know whether it's gonna be three letters
long five letters long or even sixty
letters long maybe the compiler has an
external limit anyway but in general how
can we keep going round without knowing
how many and the answer of course is
recursion
to draw you finite state automaton
diagram for a programming identifier
yeah and those of you are from my
electronics engineering department you
can say yes we've known about these for
years they just state machines so here
comes a state machine for identifies us
you have to have a starting point we had
in the carpark and we have to have one
here now and then what I'm going to do
is to say well in order to get started
on a programming language identifier the
rule is you must start with a letter not
a digit and I just didn't denote any
letter for the moment by L this state
here which I'm calling the tail piece of
the identifier is to take care of the
fact eventually that identifies could
just be a single letter it's perfectly
possible to say int I semicolon it's
just a single letter identifier so I've
got to allow for that it can be just one
that along or it can be a letter
followed by any mix of letters and
digits in any order but eventually there
has to be an end marker and of course
typically in the C programming language
the end marker is semicolon okay how do
we do that any mixture of letters and
digits stuff well here's something new
inside this tailpiece state I am saying
you can go back into yourself by
accepting more letters down at the
bottom I can say accept a digits I'll
call any digit just D at the moment so
can you see what's happening here you go
in you must have an initial letter but
once you're in the t-state you can come
back into yourself and that is recursion
but as you go back and come back into
yourself you must accept a letter or you
must have find a digit on the input
stream eventually the party's got to end
you can't keep recurring forever no good
at all you will crash you will run out
of memory so eventually it's got to be a
way out of all this morass and what I'm
going to do just so I can link up with
what noam chomsky did the great no
really like to think of everything as
well the
sentence and called it s we mentioned
this already that you know in carpark
language illegal sentences 10 10 5
because it adds up to 25 and song but to
get into this final state which
sometimes it's called the finished state
sometimes equal is called the accept
state then I need to see an E and an E
is a valid end marker and I'm saying
that in for this subset of the C
programming language you were doing here
the end marker will be a semicolon
I might later on extend that a bit
because if I do some more examples I
want to be able to accept new line as
being an end marker as well but for the
moment let's say yes its semicolon so
that's it then that is a state machine
factor this new image is the ability to
do recursion for as long as you want
until you finally bottle out the whole
thing and take the end marker and say
that's the end of my declaration okay
well what emerged from all of this stuff
about state machines and from Chomsky's
work in the mid to late 50s for every
machine you can draw like this and this
is a machine interpretation of
identifies there's always a grammatical
alternative and the more if you take
mathematical theoretician you are the
more you like rather abstruse so-called
top-down ways of thinking about thing so
Chomsky's notation let me just start you
off on this for this we'll just say look
my goal is a sentence but what seems to
be the case is that to get to sentence
I've got to take first of all an L and
then that gets me into a T State okay
Chomsky notations you can read the arrow
as being is defined as a sentence is
defined as an L any letter followed by
what I'll call a tail or a tail piece of
the identifier L and T fine
well what let's just do one example of
what a tea can be a tea look let's take
this one can be further defined as yet
another letter
followed by another team now look what's
happening here for the first time a rule
40 is developing another visit into a
tea on his right-hand side this is
technically called right recursive and
the Chomsky rules say you can be write
recursive if you do it the other way
around perversely and duty becomes T L
that's okay that's still within the
Chomsky rules it can be purely write
recursive or purely left because if I
make it right because if it's a bit more
intuitive to me and just in case you
think well this is gonna go on forever
and I can imagine the T becoming a DT
and you're taking digits forever what's
the thing that gets you out of all this
in the end and the answer is well look
back at the automaton diagrams to ha in
the end you take the escape route you
take a T is defined as being an e that's
one of the options but what about e then
ah well here's a classic example then of
something that doesn't lead onto another
rule it leaves in treat of to a leaf of
the tree a terminal symbol that goes
nowhere else what I'm hoping is there is
just a semicolon of course you've
spotted that the picture is completed
refer back to your Thomason again
there's also a write recursive option to
say yes except any digit and go back
into T so you go back into yourself
again but equally you can now write at
the bottom here and it's in the handout
we will do all of this in a linked Handa
so do read the info block of this video
find out where the handout is download
it read it you'll find in this complete
thing I've also said a letter can be
anything from a to Zed or capital a to
capital with a digit to me anything from
Norton ID that's the way you finish off
that grammar this encourages you to
think as computer sizes say top down you
start with the purity of the abstraction
of a sentence and then you develop the
detail below it
automata really I tried to show you the
whole picture you can for me from
Thomasson get a rather it's a bit
top-down but you can always get more of
an idea of how all this is built up in
sequential steps going through it
there's nothing very magic then now it's
just emphasizing what I said at the
start to every machine picture of a
circle in the hierarchy there is a
corresponding grammatical expression of
it it's just as we will go out through
the Chomsky hierarchy the machine
interpretations become more complicated
and more involving this magic thing
called memory as an ancillary to what
state is your machine in down here in
type 3 where we are at the moment all
we're saying is all you get is your
States and yes you've got to model those
correctly but you don't need ancillary
memory for any purpose
later on we'll find that we do
hierarchy where as you go inside you
make less and less demands on what you
need and if you look we can even
eliminate cast shadows which would be
cast by direct sunlight